after using it as an election campaign
issue president Trump is once again
focusing on the caravan of Central
American migrants heading to the US
border in a series of tweets Friday the
president questioned the motive of
migrants were planning to seek asylum in
the u.s. he calls it a big con those who
make it to the border though face
another hurdle getting through the
American Asylum process which requires
them to prove they fled persecution in
their homeland we had the chance to
speak to some of these asylum seekers
and hear why they've chosen to endure
such a long and uncertain journey with
each day more migrants make it to Mexico
side of the border some have camped out
in the shadow of the border fence
sequence mejor que llegar que de this
migrant says she won't cross illegally
instead she'll seek asylum at an
official port of entry she's part of a
group of LGBT migrants who are among the
early arrivals many say they were
persecuted in their home countries
because of their sexual orientation or
gender identity earlier on the journey
in southern Mexico we met this
transgender woman who asked us to
conceal her identity she claims she was
targeted in Honduras by gang members and
last year more than a dozen armed men
broke into her house and attacked her
gonna put up a surrender she says she's
been beat up and has a scar but doesn't
like to show it because it traumatizes
her more to show it
she says she fears for her life in
Honduras because gang members know where
she lives and they have her photo
younger than even if she makes it to the
US border and presents her asylum case
the odds are against her
more than 75% of asylum cases filed by
Central Americans were denied from 2012
to 2017 that's not deterring this
Nicaraguan family we met in Mexico
they're hoping to receive political
asylum in the u.s. when we asked why
Alania Molina Rocha pointed to a
newspaper assistant what is this is the
someone nosotros is a familia de
paramilitaries she says they're leaving
Nicaragua because of this and this is a
newspaper
she says this is her family on the cover
she says her family supports those that
are anti President Ortega Nicaragua and
the President sees those against him as
terrorists so they have been persecuted
she says this is a photo of their house
she says the paramilitary shot at their
house she claims that pro-government
forces opened fire on her 14 year old
son in July and detonated a homemade
bomb that lodged shrapnel in his leg he
now has to make the journey to the US on
crutches and balasso nearly yes the
member opened up again oh man but lastly
he says he was with his friend and they
started getting shot at and his friend
pushed him down and his friend died his
friend got killed a man paralyzed a car
called Cortana
no good day David when they retreated to
the mountains he says people help take
the shrapnel out with nail clippers he
thinks he still has some pieces still in
his leg they said wanted signs for the
family were posted in town so they left
Nicaragua traversed Guatemala and
eventually made it to southern Mexico
they stayed there a month when word
spread about a caravan approaching where
are you trying to go I don't think it
as an assistance or news the United
States she then looked into the camera
and made a direct appeal I present an
Ultron he knows how you see foot up for
me
Joe merrily I still appeal I really as
president Trump please help us she said
I would get on my knees and beg don't
send us back she continued we're walking
and scared you say you'll militarize the
border but I pray to God that with our
evidence of persecution you won't send
us back I fear for my family's life
before thing you're not drunk I don't
know let us say go
please mr. Trump open the doors for us I
beg you we've been in contact with the
family I spoke to the mother last night
and she says that they are struggling on
this journey they are cold
they've been enduring difficult
conditions and that they're out of money
because they've spent everything they
had on trying to get bus tickets to help
fasten the journey you said they've been
on they've been on the road for since
July four months yes and part of their
journey was even on horseback to
traverse mountainous areas no the
father's face there was incredibly
telling and wanted almost and the appeal
the appeal directly to the president she
knew exactly who she had to talk to him
mm-hmm
she certainly did very powerful story